l'armée russe a affirmé avoir utilisé
des missiles hypersonique en ukraine le
18 mars c'est la première fois que ce
type d'armes est utilisé dans le monde
lors d'un conflit voici ce qu'on lançait
alors déjà faut savoir que la russie est
le premier pays en avoir créé depuis la
chine et la corée du nord déclare
également d'avoir développé et en avoir
testé en fait la particularité de ces
missiles c'est leur vitesse selon moscou
se tirait en ukraine peuvent atteindre
les 12000 kilomètres à une vitesse qui
les rend plus pénétrant plus destructeur
et surtout plus difficile à contrer en
effet la rapidité et la manoeuvrabilité
de ces missiles fonds qui peuvent
contourner les systèmes de défense
antiaérienne et toucher des cibles
difficiles à atteindre avec des missiles
classique ainsi la cible frappé par
l'armée russe le 18 mars un entrepôt
souterrain domicile et de munitions de
l'aviation ukrainienne située dans
l'ouest du pays on va était difficile à
détruire avec des musiques classiques
selon les expériences l'armée russe
possède plusieurs types de missiles
hypersonique qu'il peut tirer depuis ses
navires ses sous marins ou encore ses
avions ce qu ils démultiplient leur
portée il convient de préciser que
certains experts militaires occidentaux
pensent que la russie pourrait exagérer
les capacités de leurs missiles
personnel